when you get into how online ads work
they are so so much creepier than you
ever give them credit for they stalk you
around the internet like
if any human being if any ex did this
they would be in jail and rightly so
what happens every time you visit any
website
is you start this amazing bidding war
for your attention and they might
literally know exactly who you are or
they might have built a picture of it
i'm joined by james ball james welcome
to the show
pleasure to be here absolute pleasure to
have you on i want to know what's it
like
interviewing edward snowden in a stadium
filled with 15 000 people sir
that was that was something of a moment
i've gotta say they've done this very
dramatic
sort of in a video build-up and then
they killed
every light in the place and so i'm
walking out to silhouette and they've
just been told to expect edward snowden
and you can see the disappointment on
the face of the people
like absolutely crashing have we been
sold a bill of goods
[Laughter]
my my sort of script line to start it
was edward are you listening
at which point he's meant to appear on
the big screens because of course it's
video link
and you just have this sinking moment in
your
sort of the longest sort of second and a
half of my life
when you come on stage and edward are
you listening and you just think
if he doesn't come up on screen this is
the rest of the interview after that was
a
total cakewalk because the nerves of
that mode have been so extreme
it's like proper metallica [ __ ] it
honestly it's you know you do you you go
around and speak as a journalist
as a reporter and a big crowd is 200
you know that is like that feels like
prime time and so you walk out to 13
000 at this like music concert venue and
you're like what the hell happened
how do you what happened in life for me
to end up in this situation here
yeah it's it's just completely
ridiculous the um
the venue did some photos from the back
of the crowd and you've just got this
huge sort of stadium crowd
and then every screen as it should be
massive picture of edward snowden
and there's this tiny dot on the stage
that's me that's me
look at me mom i made it
i did actually send it to my mom who has
who has got it in a little frame how
cool man that's awesome
uh so yes we're talking about analogous
today we're talking about the internet
you've
written a book about the internet why
did you write a book about the internet
i i wrote a book about the internet
because weirdly
for something that's kind of so
pervasive you know more than half of
all of humans are on it we do everything
in our lives by it we're doing this
interview with it you know
we do our banking it's our financial
system it's our information it's our
spies it's our
critical network and all we really talk
about
is facebook and twitter and google and
they're really important we should talk
about them you know they do matter
but we never talk about the actual
internet bit you know we talk about the
cloud or we just sort of use it and
don't think about it
and i kind of was like okay all of these
boring
invisible bits of the internet they're
not boring they're really important and
i want to do a book talking about them
instead
so that's that sort of was what i set
out when i
did it and hopefully hopefully it's
fairly successful
in like actually going look at all these
really important bits of the internet
that are just as broken and just as wild
but have nothing to do with mark
zuckerberg yeah it's um
it's mad because you're right the
internet the infrastructure
physically how it manifests and how the
the messages are actually being moved
around the world and all this sort of
stuff
the takeoff of the platform of like the
software side of things and the way that
it's experienced by people
was so great that we never actually got
to look into how
interesting or cool or otherwise all of
the stuff
underneath that was you know like you
got to see the wright brothers got to
take a little bit of a plane off and you
see them and they kind of fail a little
bit
and then there's a slightly better one
and then oh wow we've managed to get a
helicopter but it doesn't really work
that much you know we've got to attach
another rotor and do all this stuff
and then you eventually get to like
concord and you watch this whole thing
and people kind of brought along for the
ride
but the takeoff with the internet was so
intense
and so so quickly was everyone it was
just this
ubiquitous uh utility
like gas and plumbing that um we all
kind of we didn't get to see that bit
right
it is that amazing thing it's become a
utility and we sort of
you know the electrical grid is pretty
cool if you ever need to think about it
like
we have to generate the same amount of
power every day that we use
and you can't store power very well it's
really hard to do
and so there's this massive complicated
mess of a thing going on
that we had about a century maybe a
century and a half generously to build
and we don't have to think about it
because to us you flick a switch
the internet sort of 20 years ago was a
really
niche thing you know starting to catch
on you probably
you know knew someone who had it you
might have had it at home why would you
ever
want it on a phone um and then suddenly
it's critical infrastructure that we
don't think about
to that extent and that's kind of wild
because
it has really really like reshaped how
the world works and also sort of how the
world connects to each other
this idea of the internet as the cloud
is such a good bit of marketing because
someone has to like drive ships and lay
cables under the sea to do this and bury
them
at the oceans and you've got to find
sort of
a massive plot of land that's quite
cheap that you can put
huge huge data centers and aircon and
all of this
and so there's this massive network of
physical infrastructure
that we just never really had to think
about because it just appears to us
yeah so let's let's get started talk to
us about the mechanics of the internet
what did you find out about that
so there's quite an a great like
early origin story of the internet and
it's older than you think it is it comes
out of something called the arpanet
which grew out of the us military
basically
um if you've ever heard of arpa or darpa
they came out of the u.s department of
defense and were like their moonshot
secret projects uh you know if anyone
ever ran
sort of you know these are the people
who everyone thinks did mind control
and they actually were looking into bits
around that they really did
um or if we had area 51 that would be
these guys
and one of the things they were trying
to do
like this is sort of in about the 60s
was look at networking
and so computers at this time this time
are
things the size of a room that you feed
with punch cards
that cost masses and masses of masses of
money
and maybe about three universities in
the country would have one
it would be sort of a big cell in the
very narrow geek world you know we have
a computer that can do
x which would be wildly less powerful
than a calculator if anyone still has a
calculator
um and so one of the things that arpa
tried to do um universities in america
would go to it for funding saying hey we
want an even better computer that can do
this kind of calculation
and because they wanted to research
networking
and we'll get onto why um they kind of
saw a bit of an opportunity of going
well
we won't give you money for a computer
but we'll give you money to network the
one that you have
and that will mean if your computer's
really good say doing
traditional sort of physics type
equations
we'll hook you up with a university
that's really good for doing
sort of graphical calculations
and so when they need your computer they
can use it when you need theirs
you can use it and so you get more
computer
we're not buying you another one uh it's
very sort of
you know parental type relationship and
so
they said yes because if someone's
offering you money and it will kind of
help you
why not and so four universities kind of
said yes initially to connect up their
computers
with this thing called arpanet and they
just wanted to do this to do their
physics or their chemistry or their
mathematical research
they weren't sort of particularly
evangelists going wow this will be a
huge and exciting world-beating thing
um and so they had to work out the basic
stuff
and they came up with this sort of
fairly revolutionary set of ideas
that you know they were only thinking
about connecting up
first four and then hey if it works
maybe we'll have as many as like 12 or
15 on here
you know this was let's think big guys
um
and so they they were sort of thinking
right well we want to make it work quite
well
and so it won't care what data you're
sending
so networks beforehand you had a phone
network and that could only send
phone type signals uh you know you would
have perhaps a network for flight
reservations which would be really
really specialist and only send very
particular
data um and
you would charge you'd be charged for
how far your call was you know long
distance calling all of this
and the type of thing it was so if you
answered
if you added an answer phone onto a us
telephone network you had to pay more
every month
uh like just because you're connecting a
different type of thing to it
and so they came up with this idea that
this network won't care
you can send whatever on it it won't try
and understand it it'll just
send it along and we won't try and build
in a system
so that it matters how far it traveled
you know you at the moment the us
government's paying the bill for
everything
we'll just send it all out and so they
got these things connected up
it was sort of largely kicked down to
graduate students
uh to do the actual how should all of
this work
the eminent professors this was like yes
we want this network
get on with it you know one of them
oversaw the project
and sort of was actually quite into it
the rest they left to grad students who
you know very much the lowest rung of
of of the academic circle and so it sort
of came to this very first test in 1969
and um
these are you know these are nerds
they're not thinking they're doing some
big
potential first moment and so they
connected up um
stanford with ucla so two universities
west coast of the us
a couple hundred miles away and they're
on the phone to each other to try and do
their first internet connection
um and they they basically decide
that they're just gonna try and log in
to the computer in the other university
so they're not trying to do something
big you know uh you know the first
message by phone i think was something
like what hath god wrought
it's so symbolic isn't it yeah like one
step for man
one step for mankind and this one's like
right can you just give me your password
again please john
it said this is the thing like you know
you can tell whoever's done that
you know if if i was using that i'd be
is this working how would we do it
you know what had gotham was brilliant
and so they start trying to type in the
command to log
in which was login and they they type
the l
and they go to phone right i've typed
the l if you got the l
yeah type co wo
they wait yep got the o types the g
whole computer crashes
so the very first message uh sent
successfully
on what became the internet was low
oh i mean that really just put
everything else to shame doesn't it
yeah i mean it actually does end up
sounds like big dramatic sort of talking
word doesn't it something gandalf would
say yeah yeah it does
it does low we have broken the internet
you need
to restart so i also i think it's really
apt that the very first one they did
crash the whole thing
so you know start as you mean to go on
yeah nothing changes
but yeah they got it fixed they got it
built and so it became this sort of
interesting thing they found that it did
actually let them use their computers a
bit better
and the innovation that they come up
with was
whatever you send by it whatever the
results of the calculation
would go into these little things called
packets it's basically like and this is
still how the internet works
whatever you're trying to send or
receive if it's an email if it's a video
website whatever it's basically broken
up into
hundreds or in fact thousands and
thousands of little packets which are
just like little envelopes going
this is envelope one of 5000
going from here to here and so all these
envelopes get sent they all travel by a
bunch of different routes you know
whichever cables are
quiet and all the envelopes arrive with
you in the wrong order
and your computer just goes okay i've
got packet 50 here's 49. here's 48
where's 47.
reassembles them all in the right order
turns it back into
over to you and what's quite neat about
this
is it means you don't care what order
they're sent in what order they arrive
in
if something gets held up it doesn't
matter it doesn't have to arrive
you know packet 30 doesn't have to
arrive between 29 and 31.
and it turns out this is what arpa were
really interested in
this idea of being able to just split up
messages into packets
and send them and not care what route
they take
and they didn't you know plot twist they
didn't really care about the maths and
physics nerds
in the us universities what it seems
that they cared about
was nuclear weapon command and control
so this was the late 1960s you know we
are in full
full cold war territory here and
what they were looking to do was well
what happens if we have a first strike
against us and
we don't respond quickly enough and
the us has been hit and we want to
retaliate
what happens if we literally can't send
the signal from the command bunker
to the launch site you know
what if the cable that it's meant to
travel on is one of the ones that's been
hit by the nuke
okay three they might have but they were
like
how could we have it so that we can
reliably
still send the signal and be sure it
would be received
and accurate if we ever wanted to second
strike
now you can see this is a terrifying
warmongery thing
and your eyes suggest that you kind of
are um
they would also say being able to prove
that you could retaliate if you were
struck first
makes it less likely someone will strike
you part of the mutually assured
destruction
exactly it's you you can make an
argument
that by going look we could retaliate it
makes
someone else less likely to want to
strike first if you think you could
strike first and get away with it
maybe you would you know personally i
wouldn't
i don't know i like the whole i've been
reading into this a little bit recently
the mutually assured destruction
as a it gets billed
as this kind of compassionate approach
to making sure the world doesn't get
blown up it's like bro
that's not how it works it's like
the world's biggest and scariest
testosterone off isn't it yeah
yeah yeah it is precisely that
the whole thing is terrifying like i'm
quite glad i was born after that year
absolutely yeah [ __ ] knowing what's
going on there so yeah you've we've got
the the fact that what the government
were actually interested in was the
ability to have a more robust
communication system for them to
find nukes if they were struck first
yeah and so
it wasn't that they wanted to use this
nice little nerdy network to do it but
if you're going to test a new
communications technology
you don't do it on the nuclear sort of
weapon system
you want to be pretty sure by the time
that you put implement anything that's
connected to nukes
it works it works reliably it's safe
so you give it to a bunch of hyper nerds
over on the west coast
and just let let them dick around with
it for a couple of years while they try
and get the letter g to work
exactly because what do you care if uh
researcher
you know call essential mathematical
principle
it's not that's that's that's shite okay
so that's what it was like
in the beginning let's roll the clock
forward now
to when the big internet starts to be
built
what does that look like because you
alluded to it earlier on there's these
huge data centers all over the place
there's these wires that are laid
under oceans like who did that how did
they do that
where is it so the internet grew really
really slowly
and then really really fast and that's
kind of what's caused almost all of the
problems with it
so it grew from this quite useful
nerd network and got more and more
universities in
and one of the first sort of connections
they managed to get a uk university onto
it
email came really really early the queen
sent an email i think in the late 70s
uh was one of the she was one of the
first brits to send an email
you know i like to imagine she's got a
sort of alt account on reddit where she
posts
really good memes and stuff now because
she's been online longer than any of us
um and so you had you had lots of little
bits you could send
files quite early and they came up with
various protocols
to keep it all working it used to
literally there used to be a text file
sitting on one computer that listed all
the computers on the internet and what
their address was
um uh i mean this was actually
only until about the mid 70s it was for
sort of three or four years
but because they're only a few dozen
computers it's quite
easy to do is here and this computer's
here have you seen them
it's a family guy sketch where they're
talking about
when only a few people in america had
telephones
and someone rings and he goes hello and
he goes hello is this seven he goes no
this is four who's this and he goes this
is eight
i'm looking for seven he goes oh this is
four
that's kind of what it's like it's
basically like that and literally
you'd have to wait for someone to add
like have the time to update the text
file and type you on
um and so they came up with things that
would update automatically
you know if you added a new computer to
it and gave it an address all of that
kind of stuff
but they were all sort of just done in
agreement between these unis no one
really set up a
and this is the official body that will
do this and this is the
and they set out a bunch of rules on how
traffic would flow and how web addresses
would work
um on how like online addresses would
really work which
they're called ip addresses you've
probably seen them like a long string of
numbers
and so that all kind of gets worked out
when pretty much everyone on the
internet knows each other
pretty much everyone on the internet is
kind of american and either
with the government or in a university
and it rolls out quietly um
until they kind of eventually go okay
it's useful for some companies to
connect to this now
some nerds who don't work at
universities want to stay connected on
it you know they've graduated or
other people have some uses for it and
they eventually kind of went okay we'll
let
everyone on and this is sort of
during this period which is about 20
years i should say this is not
particularly fast this idea of arpanet
got replaced with the idea of the
internet
which is not again a very glamorous name
it's basically the you know the
department of defense might have a
network inside its own institution
that might have some quite sensitive
stuff on for dod employees
you might then have you know a stanford
a network for the students and the
tutors there
it might have some useful information
for new graduates you know
computers policies and so you've got
network here and network here
a bunch of other networks what's going
to connect them up
a network of networks and into that
internet yeah as opposed to the intranet
which would be the internal one
exactly that so it's literally just a
network of networks it was a totally
functional name
and they dropped us a little work bit so
it just became internet
um so you're getting to about sort of
1990 you're still
at most about a million users and this
technology has now been around since
1969.
and uh tim berners-lee comes in around
this point
um and he worked at cern um you know as
an engineer there
and came up with um with an idea sort of
um oh could we sort of make paid like
could we make something so you could see
sort of nice
nice formatted pages and he called it
the web
where he called it the world wide web
and this was basically the idea of being
able to show
pictures text all formatted as what we
now know is a web page
and his he wrote this all up as a formal
proposal
and his supervisor at cern uh
i you know if you don't know cern it's
the thing with the large hadron collider
you know
that's sort of gonna make a new big bang
or whatever
um i'm kind of hoping they'll hurry up
with that these days
so that would make the world a little
bit of a better place at the moment
wouldn't it yeah that'd be great i feel
like we could do the do-over
um and so you know very clever people at
this institution his uh supervisor
looked at this proposal
for what is now you know technology
absolutely everywhere in the world
and uh just noted on it that it was
interesting but
vague fun to me the
the single biggest technology change in
a century
interesting but vague yep
i mean you know good on them for that
i've got a cool story to interject there
tim berners-lee's
nephew is at oxford with my buddy
alex and um he met him
at one of these fancy dinners where you
got a dress like harry potter and
everything everything there's frills on
thrills
on frills and it's gold bars plated in
gold for you culturally and stuff like
that
and uh he sat down next to him and i
think maybe maybe people had um
name name tags or uh place seatings
you know with the names yeah and uh it
was like sean
berners-lee or whatever and
alex turned to him i was like oh yeah
funny like
like tim do you know tim and he was like
uh yeah he's my uncle
and alex was like holy [ __ ]
wow so that that's sort of quite a oh
oh actually oh yeah yeah like where'd
you go from there like that's the
biggest foot in mouth situation ever and
he's sat next to this poor guy for the
next like four hours or whatever at this
dinner
where he's wearing frills and a tea
cozzy for his head
so um but yeah and so that kind of was
suddenly the killer product where people
actually
really started to want to use it and it
was in the 90s you start seeing this big
swell up
of users and basically this was all done
private sector
you know you could initially connect
through your phone line there was a
thing that could sort of
change your signal modems anyone who
connected to the internet in that era
will still
know the secrets yeah
it's quite soothing if you're used to it
it is it is yeah i bet if you
if you're if you were born after 1999
probably i'm gonna guess you won't be
able to remember it because
around about sort of 2 000. i bet 94.95
you're right i'd be interested to hear
on that like if you can
what's the cutoff point tell us if you
can't remember it and tell me if you can
just give me a comment drop it in the
comments below and we're gonna work out
because that's the real millennials from
this 1984 to 1996
generation y it's can you remember the
sound of a modem that's what determines
what what generation they are that's the
full range today i bet that would work
because it's just not going to be as
iconic to you if you're a bit older
what's that sound that was annoying you
had to listen to it all the time
don't that's that is the sound of my
childhood okay don't talk
don't you talk about it like that all
right i need to go back
so the queen sent an email queen's in
the uk
sent an email to america where is it
where'd the cable come from so
we had this we had some of the early
transatlantic cables
the fun thing on the internet is it
basically piggybacked off the phone
network
people sort of found out that the way it
sent data
it could double up um but
the headache when it was sort of using
phone networks was
as anyone knows he was um you know on
the internet and then their mom wanted
to make a call
you could be kicked off the internet by
someone sort of phoning out
and you had similar problems when you
were piggybacking
on other infrastructure and so
eventually they started
laying their own cables and
internet cables are sort of wild in
there they
they are a literal physical web around
the world
and they the way they connect is not at
all neutral it's between
the places that have the money to lay
them the places that have the
old phone network and because they
mirror the old phone network and
piggyback off it
it follows the shape of it a lot and so
you've got tons of really good internet
connections
across america and across europe a lot
of the rest of the world is far less
well supplied
etc but these cables are
not like you might think you're probably
imagining something
sort of three or four feet wide for all
the data and all that
a standard transatlantic internet cable
is about the width of a hose pipe
how many of them are there there's
dozens of them
um but not not thousands or millions of
them
not thousands or millions no and they
literally
they float under the sea like in some
places the sea is so deep that they're
just floating
and unfortunate fish with particularly
sharp teeth comes in my connection to
someone when i'm podcasting with them
could just be shot
this actually happens sharks chew
through
some of the internet cables bloody
shades
it's always sharks isn't it or
alligators
great excuse if you don't want to chat
to so oh no you're
wrong i think your sparks got the
internet cape like that guy like the guy
from the world health organization when
he got
caught that's what he should have done
that's what you should have done
sorry the chalk connection
i mean much more believable to be
excused
but of course you know we've the
internet everything travels on packets
if you do lose one of the cables it's a
very brief disruption as long as you've
got other ones
everything just flows and it takes
another route it's sort of the
the magic of the internet is it's really
resilient because
it it's got it does not care what route
it takes to go to anything
and because most stuff travels at the
speed of light you know
you can just rearrange super quickly
that connection will go from
sort of islington to camden via canada
yeah yeah just a totally natural route
these cables get you through they have
they've got special boats that go out
and basically pick them up
and get the two broken ends and uh patch
them up
yeah some fella just sticks them back
together with a little bit of a little
bit of gaffer tape or whatever
um so we made this joke and we were
laughing earlier on about
oh there's some guy sat there with a
text file like how
how silly is that but there is actually
a fella that you met who's got a big red
button
on his desk yes there is a guy with a
big red tell me
about the guy with the big red button so
this guy is
uh called goran marby and uh he's the
head of an organization called
uh icahn which uh
i always have to look the name up even
though i have
covered this thing for seven years
because it is
the most it sounds like a fake kind of
james bond cover company
uh in terms of how bland it's trying to
sound it's
the internet corporation for assigned
names and numbers
no one is looking into that are they oh
god i don't want to do research on i can
no
no exactly and so what these guys
oversee
they're not for profit they're not sort
of in
any un charter they're not in the us
constitution or anything like that
they are responsible for what web
address
points to what site and so
you know and who can buy what web
address
so pretty much anyone can buy a com
but if you want to buy something that's
dot cat
you can't buy it just because you like
you know monkeys
uh you can only buy it if you're from
the catalonia region of spain
um and so there are all sorts of fights
like this
who you know how do we make sure that
people legitimately have
their own web addresses that they should
how do we know when we type
google.com into a browser is taking us
to the real google.com
um how do we keep the internet joined up
and everyone agreeing on all of this
um you know one of the fights that these
guys have to sort out
is who should be able to own
dot amazon um because there's a very
very big tech company worth more than a
trillion dollars
uh who would say well we have a lot of
trademarks and patents here you know we
we would like dot amazon please and
there's several countries who have the
world's biggest and most important
rainforest
uh in their geography who would say
actually guys um we were here first
all of this is uh gora and marby and so
you know if any organization can sort of
claim to have
a lot of oversight of the rules of the
internet
you know he icam is responsible for this
thing called dns
um sort of dynamic um name service and
it's
what connects up the actual sort of
address of your computer
um to web web addresses that we all use
um and so it's this incredibly
important system um because
not only is it the rules and the sort of
wrangling about that
it's if you can trick domain name
systems
you can do a lot of sort of quite nasty
stuff
if you can sort of make it so that a
load of internet users
in one region even suddenly they're
typing in say
hsbc and it takes them not to the real
hsbc
but to a site that looks just like it
owned by fraudsters
and they type in their login and their
password you've done nothing wrong
you've
checked the web address you've checked
the little passcode
it's taken you out there and let's say
though that you're
in china and you're looking for
information on a protest or an
opposition thing
and the government messes with web
addresses
you could be taken and actually found by
authorities and dragged away
um you know people can censor and change
information
and so goran marvie's got this really
important job trying to oversee all of
this with no legal authority
what are they where is he based so he's
based he's based in los angeles
so it's in these little sort of out of
town offices on an industrial estate
they've got like two floors just so
unassuming fella
sat in the ass end of la with a big red
button
trying to desperately control the
internet yep so he's this swedish
software engineer by background you know
worked in telecoms
and uh yeah he when he got this job as
see
as sort of the director of icam his
friend bought him a big red
button to put on his desk to sort of
show you know it's a bit like that thing
in the it crowd where she's holding the
internet
you know if if anyone is it's him he
really does have a hold of the internet
doesn't he oh my god
right okay so that's that's some stuff
to do with the infrastructure and the
mechanics of how the internet works
you also looked at the way that
advertising works online as well didn't
you can you
tell us what you learned from brian
o'kelly i i will do i should really say
um
the the issue for poor goran is uh and
you know why he keeps his butt
on his desk is uh he let me press it uh
[ __ ] what happened did everyone's
internet go down so i mean i've got to
say i was hoping or at least you know a
big sort of you know
inside or something you press it and
it's
it's like it's a big elevated button it
looks like something that should be in a
nuclear power station or something
leave a little press it absolutely
nothing
not a single thing and of course it's
got this reminder where he's like
no one actually has power in the center
of the internet
everything's done by consensus
everything's done by this
mind-numbing thing where everyone has to
agree every rule change
and so it's all disintegrating and
falling apart
you've got all these people making all
this money on the internet and then the
actual
rules that hold it together that people
like him and not-for-profits have to
oversee
are crumbling and so you know it was
this quite
sort of you sort of like you've got a
big red button on your desk
that's cool and then it's sort of like
no no it's him saying that he's kind of
tasteless
it's the antithesis of his control yeah
exactly that i you know i half won them
you know maybe a little bit it's like
maybe one day it'll work yeah that's it
he's desperately what you don't know
is that goran marby is a
low-key super criminal who is lying in
weight
and has slowly worked his way up from
being a swedish programmer to the
arsenal la
and he's slowly creating a big red
button that's going to shut down the
internet
and he's just getting all of our
suspicion away from it by going yeah
don't touch the button
look press it press it press it it's
never what it never worked for me and
then
one day he runs away with all of the
internet money and we're all we're all
left having to ring each other again
so and my fingerprints are on it so your
fingerprints are on it who's that james
ball is that british guy
get him uh okay so um advertising
brian or kelly what did you learn from
him so
this this guy is really interesting so
when i meet him we're in the middle of a
sort of
full new york ad office uh
all of the meeting rooms are named after
uh comic book characters
so we're in sort of peter parker you
know it's all very
tech company all of this and he's the
ceo at the time i speak to him
um and this company's just been sold for
you know
more than a billion um so
he's sort of big shot in advertising on
the internet all of this
and he basically walks in and says he is
the guy that invented programmatic
advertising
so that system where every time you
visit a website
you see all those annoying automated
adverts
all the embarrassing stuff that you
looked at last week
yeah yeah that one terrible sort of sofa
that you looked at drunk on ikea
um you know there could be much worse
examples but let's go for that one that
then follows you around
or you know you bought some new cutlery
when you moved flat six months ago
and still every ad on the internet is
for cutlery sets as if you're a weird
fork fetishist that takes careful
pronunciation
very well done there very very precise
speech
it's um you know all of those but also
you know this one's a weird trick that
doctors don't want you to know all of
this
all of this is his fault um and he
admitted this
like off the back of it and
when you get into how online ads work
they are
so so much creepier than you ever give
them credit for
tell us i want to know how creepy this
is basically
they stalk you around the internet like
any if any human being if any ex did
this they would be in jail and rightly
so
and so the ad networks facebook runs an
ad network google runs one amazon runs
one
then then there's a bunch of other ones
any website
that shows adverts from that company
asks to put
one of the ad network cookies on your on
your computer
um and when you tick that yes to the
cookie box it turns up on
every bloody website you visit always
that's one of the things that you're
agreeing to
and that's just a little line of text on
your computer
doesn't put anything else on your thing
it's just something going
hey this person visited this website it
doesn't even say that it's just a line
of text
other websites can look for what cookies
are on your computer
so let's say you go to new york times um
earlier in the day and then you go to
you know
some kind of anime fan site or something
later in the day
it'll have a look and go oh this guy was
on the new york times earlier
i recognize i recognize that cookie
all of that's stored over at the ad
network you can't see
any of what they know about you now
you'll have dozens and dozens of these
on your computer and so what happens
every time you visit any website
is you start this amazing bidding war
for your eyeballs for your attention
and they might literally know exactly
who you are
or they might have built a picture of it
so the advertiser let's say
someone who wants to sell you know my
book
um my publisher if they did this
would do here's a list of people who've
bought books from us in the past who are
subscribers to our mailing list
we don't want to target these people we
want to target people like them
so they'll do like a seed list and go
people who look a bit like this
and then essentially these sort of data
brokers
can look at that and come up with a set
of characteristics that you might want
and so they'll keep an eye out for that
and so it might be a new york times
reader it might be someone who's
gotten to why you know they might have
all sorts of stuff or it might just be
people that we guess are aged between 25
and 50
living in the uk uh and living in cities
it can be really vague it can be really
specific
and when you visit the site
it will try and look at as much
information on you as it can if you're
logged in it will take that information
but it will also see all the cookies it
can and go hey
we've seen all of these cookies and send
it over
to ad platforms which then go
right here's who we think this person is
um how much would you pay
to serve them this advert and this might
go to
dozens and dozens of places that are
each trying to sell dozens and dozens of
ads
and so we each want to look through the
cookies and go okay someone with that
cookie
i would pay 0.00 one cent to show them
this rubbish generic advert
but actually that's a good cookie i've
got an advert that wants that cookie
i'd pay 0.1 cents for that or one cent
for that
and so they all come back with their
bids and eventually you see the six or
seven adverts
of the people that would pay most to see
you
what that means has gone on in that like
tenth of a second
where you're loading a web page is data
about you didn't just go
to the three or four to the web owner
or even the web owner and the people
whose adverts you're seeing
it went to hundreds and thousands of
companies
the pace that this happens at is mental
i can't believe that they're able to do
dynamic ad
targeting without it completely breaking
the internet or making you just
walk from web page to web page you know
what i mean it feels like that should
take half an hour doesn't
it like you think at auction and it sort
of it's all
in microseconds now because this is how
the internet makes its money so they've
made it really really efficient
why are they called cookies is it
because of crumbs
uh yeah it's exactly that it's from i
think it's from the hansa gretel thing
so even that the hansel and gretel
story's creepy as hell as well
yeah oh yeah all of this is creepy
around everything to do with the
internet
is like this sort of fluffy
teletubbies world up top and then
dante's inferno
just existing below it do you not think
it's so weird
okay so we know that people are tracking
us around the internet
we know that there are a combination
of sort of lobbyists private interest
groups
people that are outside the purview of
government but also non-profits who are
independently trying to wrangle the
internet and get it under control
how does all of that tie into national
security and surveillance
well your core thing here is sorry i'm
being bitten by a cat
so this dude here's a get so good
sir he's in trouble there he just bit my
arm
so all of this starts to matter for
national security because
it's not as if we're just going on the
internet 15 minutes a week now and
you know posting to a message board
about our favorite show
firstly it's got all of our lives on it
you know most of us now if you start
thinking about the internet being
whatsapp imessage sort of facetime skype
all of these things as well as all your
social media profiles
as well as everything you keep in the
cloud on google drive or whatever
most of us have basically all of the
intimate details of our lives
and that's before we get anywhere near
dating sites and
you know whatever pics people have been
sending on tinder or grinder or bumble
um this is all intrinsic to us
and then it's intrinsic to the global
sort of financial system now
you know most people that can access
their banks through it their savings
their investments
a lot of clearing runs on systems that
are
at least adjacent to the internet and
anyone who might be of interest to any
spy agency in the world or any hacker in
the world
lives online you really can't live off
the grid now you can minimize yourself
but you know any spy or diplomat has got
a wife they've got kids they've got
people like that that you could access
information on
so just for intelligence they're going
to you know you're going to have spy
agencies all over the internet
if you then also are trying to track for
terrorists you know it's one thing to
kind of go
oh the cultural attache from russia
who's just been assigned to the embassy
in my country
who previously seems to have worked
entirely in the police and military
hmm could that be a spy might sort of
keep an eye on him
that's one thing if you're trying to
look for a right wing extremist or
sort of some of the terror that's been
done by islamist groups
there you don't know who you're looking
for
and you have you know you can be a
western government with a very
sort of clear motive um
you might suddenly want to sort of pass
as much of the internet as you can
to see if people are trying to look up
how to do terror attacks etc
and so they want to look all over it
you've then got countries wanting to
disrupt each other
and so we've seen sort of attacks from
that were later attributed to russia
on ukrainian banking systems power
systems etc
um we quite famously the us
israel and the uk did what's called the
stuxnet attack
where they managed to come up with this
incredibly aggressive computer virus
that's the most effective worm in
history wasn't it
yeah i mean they kind of bungled it in
that it was
it's lucky that the bit they bungled was
how widely it spread
rather than the payload because they
wanted it just to spread to this
particular type of industrial controller
used in
iranian nuclear centrifuges and someone
basically
decided this isn't working well enough
and made it spread
way more aggressively which is how it
got
onto the loads and loads and loads of
internet systems where people are going
this is really weird computer virus it
doesn't seem to do anything
then it looked into it one hang on if
there's one particular type of
you know industrial board it's connected
to it does a bunch of weird commands
and those weird commands basically would
make a centrifuge
spin faster and faster then try reverse
direction then spin faster again
and literally explode um
now and it worked at least to an extent
although they got caught now if you can
start doing physical explosions by
internet attacks you look into it
and so stuxnet was part of a much wider
program getting ready in case there was
a us
or sort of conflict with iran they tried
to get in every system in that country
in their critical infrastructure
to disable as much of it as they
possibly could ahead of a war
that was it's kind of like a um like a
dead man switch type thing or like a
not like a mutually assured destruction
that's not mutually that's just assured
destruction isn't it yeah
and so what happens when you're dealing
in a world where
one side could wipe the other out they
try and do the same
so they're not necessarily trying to get
in and break everything right now
but they're trying to get the access so
that if they needed to they could
and so swirling around us on the
internet on these sort of
you know on the same hosepipe cables
that we're using to share
gifts and uh you know whatever else
you've got this invisible war going on
all around us that drags us into it
as well as you know organized crime to
try and mine bitcoin
as well as just trying to pick up state
secrets bank details
you've got this absolute swirling
unregulated conflict
in the real world we've at least got the
laws of armed combat we've got the un
we've got some restrictions no one's
ever thought to do that for cyberspace
so
we don't have you know a list of what
counts as an escalation when does
spying or industrial espionage crossed
into an attack
you know we had um the wannacry attack
which hit computers across the world but
notably hit the nhs
um and it seems like it was targeted at
someone else entirely but again spread
brilliantly
and literally stopped equipment used in
operating theaters from working
it stopped ecg's from working because
they were all on windows xp
and so this this attack that was aimed
either at ukraine or
spain suddenly took out and did millions
of damage
missed the mark and wrecked the nhs for
a couple of weeks
and i mean could have killed people you
know people
rely on this equipment to keep them
alive so let's say let's say that
someone does like
cross the line whatever that would mean
they go from
state surveillance or um state
protection
into something that could be seen as an
act of war or whatever it might be
who who gets called in to do that is it
just on the nation states to to wag
fingers at each other
so this is this is the thing we don't
have a we don't have anything to decide
how this should be arbitrated
but what we do have at the moment is
it's like this weird sort of
middle ages type thing where people
don't just rely on the state you don't
now have a bunch of companies with
private armies thankfully
well you've got a few uh but we don't
tend to like those companies but
sony doesn't have its own militia
operating in each country
i'd love that man so like i would
imagine tim cook
with a spartan helmet on and a
shield and on the front of the shield
there's just the apple logo
and then you've got you've got all yeah
all the rest of them behind it you
shall not pass that could be another one
wouldn't apple's soldiers uniforms look
amazing it'd be so slick yeah exactly
but after
after after about four years they'd need
to be replaced
whereas amazons would be like really
shoddy but there'd be loads of them
yeah there would be billions and
billions of them and they'd be able to
churn them out at a rate like no one
else would know
amazon would just be just jeff bezos
pair of aviators on and just a
a sea of drones
oh god just yeah that's all he's got
it's just him
with his aviators on and a sea of drones
also i uh had on the podcast a guy
called bruce stuckwith
from turner duckworth graphic design
company and he's the man who created the
amazon smile logo
wow okay that's quite a cool claim to
favor bro
with stark it's so good he's certainly
meeting with jeff bezos and jeff bezos
said
uh they gave it over to him and uh
jeff's assistants are there and they're
like right yeah
jeff likes it should we should we move
it on to focus groups and blah blah and
just like no no we don't need focus
groups
and though well jeff this is quite a big
it's quite a big deal
doing the read the the read the thing
it's like late 90s just like getting
real big as well
jeff maybe we should just he's like
anyone who doesn't like this logo
doesn't like puppies
you made the amazon logo and jeff bezos
said anyone who doesn't like this logo
doesn't like puppies like there is no
bigger claim to fame man
that is that is excellent that is you've
got to give that credit he's just some
fella bruce is just some guy
lovely british dude from downing i think
he said surrey
and um i was just chatting about
chattanooga i'm just this guy he does
metallica he does coca-cola he does
samsung he does
and he's just some dude with a team of
100 graphic designers that are all
absolute freak savages like unbelievable
at the job
and that's him so that's that's my
that's my cool story so okay we don't
have
sony and stuff like that they don't have
private militias
online they kind of do because it turns
out like
because we don't have all of this agreed
there is way more going on every day in
the online world
in terms of attacks and defenses and
checking everything out
and companies largely have to protect
themselves
and so you've got all of these places
like outsource
to these sort of online security
companies
um i visited one called symantec they
were actually the one that discovered
stuxnet
and there are us companies so they kind
of went oh we found this really
interesting new attack
and then eventually he had to kind of go
um it actually looks like it was made by
the u.s
government credit didn't they said it
but um they sort of they have these
secure operating
centers and uh you go in and it's
it's sort of all id you're not meant to
take your phones in
you've got a man trap of doors so you're
in like um
a door locks behind you and then you're
held and watched on cctv
another one comes through all of this
and then they monitor
billions of points of data every day for
their paying clients
because they sit inside their networks
and go
is suddenly more than usual being sent
out is there an attack
that we recognize is there all of this
and so you've got this weird
sort of world where you know the same
people who do our anti-virus software
and we sort of think of as pretty
innocuous
behind the scenes they've got these sort
of hundreds of people watching all the
time
for sort of cyber threats and how
serious they are
and if they need escalating they have
like hotlines to the
fbi and to the sort of homeland security
into all of these people
um and so it's it's basically this
ungoverned sort of battlefield with all
of us sitting in the middle of it kind
of going you know
just browsing around shopping not kind
of noticing everything sailing past it
james i'm telling you man
we're in teletubbies land and they're
down there in the seventh circle of hell
battling battling demons and stuff like
that with a massive sword out final
fantasy
yeah i mean it kind of is though it's
just this the internet because
because all the companies use this
really utopian mission language
we kind of all thought of them as cuddly
until a few years ago
it does have this like halo sort of
lovely floaty image
and then you're like god no this is this
is trench warfare
this is one of the things that i noticed
upon reading your book
that we personify a lot of things
in the world right so we personify
thomas the tank engine he's a tank
engine he doesn't need a face right but
he's got a face
and he's got a personality and stuff
like that and i think naturally we want
to ascribe even people's cars right this
oh she's
she's feeling a little slow today and
it's like no it's a mechanical vehicle
it just does the thing it's supposed to
do it's
the definition of utilitarian um and we
personify the internet as well
right in in very very similar sort of
way it's given this
new world like the 60s man free love and
information and stuff like that but
giving it a personality and
romanticizing about it appears to
actually probably be making us a little
bit weak to what's properly going on
so does taking a more utilitarian
approach help here because i can use a
hammer
to knock a nail in or i can use a hammer
to hit you in the head
and that's i think that's exactly right
i think that's sort of the
where we have to move past with the
internet this is
you know this is the new technology of
our generation
and in the book i kind of liken it to
when we
got industrialization in factories
in the end it's made us better off it's
made stuff cheaper we can produce more
we get more out of what we have
you know we have a lot of modern society
thanks to it
but initially it sucked
it made rich people way richer it let
them dump
pollution uh sort of into water and
rivers they
worked people for very low wages in
atrocious health and safety conditions
for very long hours and so a few people
got really really disproportionately
wealthy and all of the negative effects
pushed their way down society onto the
rest of us
now the internet's not quite as blatant
as a big
sort of factory churning out pollution
in front of you but it's working in just
the same way the technology is bringing
the benefits
to the people sort of who helped build
it
and so it benefits governments who have
been involved in the internet since its
inception
it benefits money you know the finance
model of the internet the
venture capital that built all of the
tech companies we know
the people who get really rich on our
data and centralizing that
is it benefiting us we've got
misinformation we've got less money we
are
sort of losing some of our high streets
we are not getting
all of the upside of this we're getting
some of it
i think most of us would go actually if
you could turn off the internet tomorrow
and wind technology back to 1990
we'd say no and that would be the right
answer
but are we actually harnessing this tool
for us
or are we letting it just because it's
good overall
and because we've got this fluffy view
of it are we letting the people
who've always had their like hands on
the levers
get all the benefit and we've got to
move it back to being a thing in the
real world
and the thing that we think about if we
want to
so have control of it and have the perks
of it and that's what we don't do and
need to
well i mean what would be the
psychological equivalent of
some nefarious factory owner 100 years
ago dumping his
waste into the local lake like it
would be the companies of silicon valley
racing to the bottom of the brain stem
to use every evolutionary trick in the
book to ensure that you
you maximize your time on site anyone
who spent time looking at tristan harris
from the
center for humane technologies work
about the
addictive nature of technology and and
all of the
real crazy militarized
weapons weaponized uh military-grade
tactics that are being used to ensure
that we stay on our phones and we stay
on site and we do
like the guy that created infinite
scroll
said in adam although's book that it was
the single biggest mistake of his life
the guy that made into infinite scroll
which is on every
website now facebook twitter youtube
whatever it might be
it's an incredibly common thing if you
talk about people who were
sort of involved in the early days of
the internet or in building some of this
or
you know whether you see them in in adam
also it's very good book actually or um
you know to the one side
it's called is irresistible is it sir
it's not i can't remember
um um it will be linked because whenever
i mention about can you type out a
maltering
um whenever i mention a book and i don't
know the rise of addictive technology
and the business of keeping us hooked
yeah um
go and check that out it's really cool
if you're interested in looking at
it's like it's quite a little old as
well in this like
2013 2014 i think so it was before the
center for humane technology came around
and um yeah adam alter irresistible
really good book if you want to
find out a little bit more about how
tech companies are manipulating us
but yeah so the people who built this
the people i spoke to you know steve
crocker was there
um was a guy who expected for the book
he was there in that very first meeting
where they crashed the internet
um you know typing in login um you've
got
you know brian o'kelly who built its
adverts you've got people who helped
fund it
and they all sort of act as if it's not
the result of their actions
and i think some of that is dissonance
and some of it's just that this thing's
become this runaway train
and so you see people kind of freak out
and
part of the thing is it's built into the
technology that it's got to keep doing
stuff like this
networks centralize power they
centralize money they centralize
resources
um that's most obvious in a social
network
if you started 10 new social networks
tomorrow
um are you really gonna move off the one
that all your friends are currently on
and let's say you move to one of them
and it's great
you're gonna try and get your friends to
move to that one not to move
separately across the other ten and
other stuff everything about the
internet we always talked about it as
this long tail
information wants to be free it's gonna
level us out it's gonna
a lot of people saying that believed it
genuinely and wanted it to do that
but by its nature it wants to centralize
power centralized money
centralized people centralized data and
so
a little bit like you know industrial
capitalists will want to move money that
way
and so you make laws that tax it and
push it all back the other way
you know that's why we have regulations
so that you can't cut safety standards
that's why we have
laws that's why we have wages you know
wage requirements all of that we built
society
to cope with what
industrial capitalism wants to do and to
mitigate it
we need to now rebuild society to deal
with what
information capitalism or the internet
wants to do
so it wants to centralize all the power
that way
that's fine as long as it's helping us
overall but just because it wants to do
that doesn't mean we have to let it
one of the things that's a common theme
with a lot of the guests that i've had
on recently
is i think that the world is moving
so quickly that not only can our
evolution
not keep up with it and our inter-social
dynamics not keep up with it we have no
idea how to talk
to the opposite sex anymore and go out
on a date
and all this sort of stuff but what
moves even more slowly than
the most flexible most adaptive
creatures on the planet
is legislation like the ability
for governments and state agencies
to catch up with this pace of change
that we've said ourselves you know
in the last 20 years from 2000 to 2020
the landscape in terms of technology and
um
connectivity isn't even in the same
universe
like if you'd been in a coma for 20
years from the year 2000 until now and
you woke up you'd be like
and we can do what what what and
you know so i think um there's this
quote from
goethe i think where he talks about the
fact that all societies swing from one
extreme to the other
and then end up finding a virtuous mean
and
inevitably i think that's what happens
because technology is always going to
move ahead and then
kind of like slow your grandma on the
walk around the playground
like she's slowly gonna catch up and
then she gets there and then there's
another leap
and oh okay now we need to work out
what's going on with augmented reality
or virtual reality okay now we need to
work out what's going on with
uh bioengineering and biotech okay now
we need to you know i mean like every
single time that this happens and this
is the fear
if anyone who's read super intelligence
by nick bostrom
which is an unbelievable book about the
take off of artificial intelligence
um that takes this game
to its nth degree to the final point
which is that if you have a super
intelligent agent
in artificial intelligence before you
have fixed the control problem
which is how do you ensure that you
don't have perverse uh incentives and
that everything is instantiated
correctly
that's it that's the end of the human
race that is everything over
and all of these little things all of
these little games that we played where
it's like oh well look you had the
you had the farming revolution and then
you killed a bunch of animals and then
you had the industrial revolution and
you polluted a little bit of the planet
and then you had
fossil fuels and we kind of gave you a
this got a dry run a number of times
where you moved forward as a society
very quickly and then you started to
realize what some of the
sort of more malicious side effects of
doing that was and then you had it with
technology
we even gave you a little bit of a taste
like look you guys you had this
lowest common denominator echo chambers
existed people's opinions got polarized
and moved out to the sides and all this
sort of stuff
and then you done gone [ __ ] up and in
the year 2105
singularity occurred you hadn't fixed
the control problem and now you're all
slaves for us and
this is just neo from the matrix flying
around
so it's kind of how it goes so if people
have never played it by the way it's um
the paperclip game if you just search
paperclips on
uh on on the app stores it's really
cheap and
good way to pass a day during lockdown
but also
just the best illustration of what goes
wrong with an ai
uh quite subtly you're just an ai making
paper clips
works nicely but i think sort of in
in the run up to sort of tackling this
stuff
i think it's almost unrealistic in terms
of optimism to expect
sort of legislation to be able to keep
up because
until something feels like a high
priority they never get there
um well there's real world problems
right so they end up playing
whack-a-mole though they end up sort of
trying to do
something narrow about a certain aspect
of social media and they'll do a narrow
fix on that or a narrow fix on
hate speech or increase the requirement
for moderators or
and you know it's it's a bit like sort
of trying to tackle flooding but a
teacup at a time
what tends to have to happen is that you
get to a point of crisis
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
a crisis caused by the thing that you're
fixing
but you know it's usually related
but you you know we got the modern
welfare states
sort of its early steps off the back of
the great depression
you know we got government actually
taking a bigger role in life
we got the nhs out of world war ii
um you know that they are pretty direct
effects of each other
even if you know even if it's not oh
the solution to war is to have a health
service um
we are at least at this point
hitting some crises and they're awful
crises
but we're in a crisis of populism we're
in a we're
going to be in an economic crisis that
makes 2010 look awful
with a global pandemic there is at least
the chance that we use this to reassess
and we use this to get ahead
if we have you know if we accept that we
have to change a lot and to build a law
and to rebuild from an economic crash we
haven't even started feeling yet
then we may as well do it to try and fit
the era
and so on the one hand we actually have
an opportunity
stuff actually changes off the back of
big crises
the sort of fear side of that is
this is such a big and awful crisis that
how bad would it be to waste it um
that's an interesting way to look at it
to actually look at the crisis as an
opportunity
we've got a chance that it's not an
indefinite chance if we don't tackle a
bunch of this
now it will get much much worse over the
next decade and we'll have to tackle it
again
all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna make
you put your money where your mouth is
james
you are governor transnational
international global governor of the
planet
and you're allowed to high level enact
some policies
or create some agencies what do you do
sir i'm assuming i can't just embezzle
and uh
make a moon base no that would be
awesome just you and elon musk
just with a massive fat cigar elon would
have a spliff wouldn't he
massive fat cigars just just sat there
yeah no you can't do that yeah ah
i i i got exactly the sight worked out
for my moon base too
um i think we've got to work out
something around
how our data is used and who owns the
rights to it
everyone likes saying date is the new
oil they sort of miss that that makes us
the crushed up dinosaurs and plants
you know i don't want to be in the pipes
i want to benefit from it
um so we need to work out if there are
sort of hundreds of billions of profits
every year being made of this
how do we share them if it's a natural
resource
of our own lives it needs to have some
sort of public ownership
as well as regulation on its use just
sort of think of it
in privacy terms is nuts and restricted
um we need rules governing cyberspace
that enorms
governing that we have to at least get
you know the laws of armed combat do not
work perfectly but at least we
have something to point to and go this
is
who would enforce it because we're
talking we're not just talking about
stuff that happens within nation states
usually
would you have to have some sort of
equivalent of like the geneva convention
essentially yeah um and you know who
enforces the geneva convention in
practice it's not like
a bunch of un people parachuting if you
sort of break it and fix everything but
we have at least a standard that we know
you're meant to be going by we have
the basis for it we know what it should
look like
um i mean all of these things are flawed
flawed tools
but at the moment we have nothing and i
would rather a flawed tool than no tool
right
yeah like sod the perfect being the
enemy of the good i would i would accept
the mediocre at this stage
um we need to sort of think about
our rights and how they work we need to
essentially try and
work out why does everything on the
internet have to fit
this weird hyped silicon valley model
you know all everything on the internet
is backed by venture capital
which basically says don't worry about
trying to build a good
business try and build the biggest in
the world
or fail so you can't go and just build a
nice
you know the equivalent of a mom and pop
store or
a chain of seven or eight restaurants or
something like that you have to go all
out for growth
or be nothing and this really really
suits venture capital and it's it's a
small handful of winners
but that's why almost everything's based
on advertising that's why
everything is competing so aggressively
for our attention it's why
we're constantly on this treadmill we
need
to sort of actually tell them to chill
the [ __ ] out
and uh sorry no no i i think that
trickles down into the way that we
operate as well right so you see the
winner takes all situation even me with
this podcast
like the listenership to this is
i couldn't even dream of the growth that
we're getting it's insane
and yet i'm still thinking oh well
i know that this guy's doing like this
many million plays per month and i
would be good if we got here and i'm
thinking like because
the friction has been removed
from first competition and then secondly
you being able to see
the people that are within there is no
longer a well joe rogan's american i
could never do what he does in america
it's like no bro you're in the same
league as everybody that does the stuff
that you do
you as a writer and as an author like
there is no reason why your book
shouldn't be the next [ __ ] war and
peace or
you know whatever like impossible i
would take those sales
yeah um that's it i i i just think it
it's like we've got that psychological
imperative
and we don't need every single financial
model imperative do that we have to work
out
how can you have good small and
medium-sized businesses on the internet
because venture capital is killing us
man like it's why
uber comes in and wrecks
the sort of whole delivery market in
your town um you know it's why
these things don't exist in isolation
it's why airbnb starts
ripping up the hotel business but also
making it harder to lease an apartment
everything's going to true sorry did you
did you look at whether or not uber
loses money on every taxi ride because i
heard this but i don't know if it's
truth
they they deny it i stand by it
um basically they say if you if you just
look at it on
the costs of doing the journey each
journey is profitable
and i'm like yeah but you know
if i if i pretend that i don't have to
pay my rent every month
i make a fortune each month that you
know
turns out i don't i i make it i make a
living
so they go if you knock off all of our
fixed costs and all of our research
costs and all of our development
and all of our xyz we're not
in practice if they need to keep
borrowing money every year to fund their
business
they're losing money every ride and they
are losing money every ride
still heard it here first ladies and
gentlemen james ball drops the bomb
about uber
look james man um it's been awesome
really interesting insight about the
internet
uh so the system who owns the internet
and how it owns us
will be out when this podcast drops so
it will be linked in the show notes
below
audible version stuff like that uh there
is an
audible version coming out the same day
uh narrated by me
i'm afraid um oh dude i love that
so yeah it's my first time doing one so
sorry if it's awful
i'm sure it'll be great that's uh that's
awesome where should people go they want
to check out some more of your stuff
where should they go
sir they can go to bit.ly forward slash
read the system
about this they can go to jamesrball.com
to
see other stuff i work on or they can
find me on twitter at
james rb uk amazing man
fantastic thank you so much i'm uh i'm
now going to go and get myself a vpn
uh never open my laptop again maybe a
nuclear bunker
that's it that's it man thank you so
much for your time cheers james sassing
thanks very much man enjoyed that
[Music]